one of the Republican lawmakers they are
louie gohmert and things boiled over
with him during the hearing he blasts
his struck for the impact he had on
public trust and the FBI and his
personal behavior the disgraced mr. what
this man has done gentleman from Texas
will suspend for a moment is the
disgrace and it won't be recaptured
anytime soon because of the damage
you've done to the justice system and
I've talked to FBI agents around the
country you've embarrassed them you've
embarrassed yourself and I can't help
but wonder when I see you looking there
with a little smirk how many times did
you look so innocent into your wife's
eyes and lied to her about mr. chairman
it was a free-for-all and you heard that
comment and do you need your medication
congressman Louie Gohmert did you lose
your temper or do you intend to bring up
his personal life decisions no I didn't
go into an intending to do that but as i
sat there listening to him so smugly his
little smirk and he is lied repeatedly
and he knew he was lying he knew I knew
he was lying
and yet he still would lie and I'm
telling you the the unfortunate thing is
about that last exchange I had with him
it may have clouded over a very very
important story and that is that he was
told by the intelligence community
Inspector General's investigator Frank
Rucker that they had found an anomaly in
the emails going to and from Hillary
Clinton's unauthorized private server
and it was when they forensic Lee
examined the anomaly they found embedded
information and it was a foreign entity
not Russia but a foreign entity that was
well that was getting every single one
of hurt over over 30,000 email so a
congressman just to shot me this show
just to stop Russia so you're saying
that in Hillary Clinton's emails they
were forwarded to somebody else yes and
it was because they were hacked and
Horowitz didn't point that out
you know they and and the previous story
you know that Comey gave us well it was
not a good server that was possible that
it got hacked but there was no evidence
it was hacked and then we find out and
that's what I brought out today that the
intelligence community AG brought it to
their attention cuz they did nothing
nothing and this is a foreign entity not
related to Russia in the lead that is
getting everyone there were only four of
over 30,000 emails they didn't get they
were going to and from constant
compromised America's security
congressman one of the many people who
questioned Peter struck today and will
probably cry so Lisa page tomorrow at
about 1:30 Eastern Time congressman
thanks so much thanks Brian